my question for you is where do you
think your biggest potential for being a
philanthropist lies is it in the work
you've done is it in your money the
money you can raise
um your claim your fame what do you
think that is the uh it's a very good
question i um
while there's no need to get at any
violins for me certainly i'm not a
wealthy
individual as philanthropists go so i um
as of now maybe that will change it
someday
can't write the big checks in those
circles so um part of my so
at the outset that inspires me to try
and contribute in as many other ways as
possible and um which is raising money
um but also
a lot of the things that i've found that
i've been able to bring to my
philanthropy is my producing skills
which is
you know what i do for a living
everything needs producing
and uh fundraisers need producing
political campaigns need producing um
awareness public relations awareness
campaigns need producing and in some
sense producing is really just a
big fancy word for
ideas and then putting them into action
and um to me that's a very exciting
combination that's sort of what that
that's that's how my that's what i run
on is that combination there are some
people who specialize in having ideas
and there are some people who specialize
in putting ideas into action and then
there are um creative producers um whose
job is to really do both so that's a
skill that i
um
like to bring feel that i can bring to
my philanthropy where um you know in any
um cause i get involved in am i gonna
write the million dollar check no but am
i going to
hear what the organization is what the
cause is try and think of great ideas
for events for pr try and figure out
ways to put those ideas into action and
then try and help raise the money to
make bring that all to fruition yes